the idea that the market is always
rational and that people always make
these rational decisions
is utter nonsense you want to live your
dream and
and the beauty of doing that as quickly
as possible is that as soon as you start
living it that dream will change
your dreams grow
be patient
have a few companies that you really do
understand and buy them when the market
fluctuates which it inevitably will and
that's that's it there's no
one-size-fits-all man
hey believe nation in today's interview
i sit down with a very well-known and
successful investor who i've looked up
to for a long time named phil towne
he's very well known for writing amazing
books like invested uh rule one and
payback time which i would all recommend
you checking out if you're interested in
investing
and he also runs an education company
called rule one where he's helping
inspire millions of people to learn
investing on their own so they can take
control of their lives in today's
interview we discuss everything from
building wealth to success to really
happiness and really mastering your life
so if that seems interesting to you i
know you'll love this interview so sit
back relax and enjoy the show
with the series i'm doing um
you know uh and for the viewers who
haven't seen the the other episodes i've
created um i'll put a link in the
description for that
uh my goal and for people to tune in and
uh almost see me kind of go through the
trials and and errors of learning to be
a great investor um since that is my
my all-time goal even though i run a
business right now eventually i'd like
to shift to uh being a great investor so
one of uh you know connecting with guy
speer manesh and then finally uh phil
town who is actually the person who
introduced me to those individuals
without even knowing it so when i was 19
i went to college and i found it a waste
of time
and
i saw a youtube video from you on how to
invest your first a thousand dollars
and that video you laid out a specific
set of books and
those books you laid out guy manesh your
book were the first five books i ever
read
that were non-fiction and
without that
um path laid out for me uh i don't know
where i'd be so i just wanna uh
acknowledge uh and say thank you
oh you're very welcome those are good
books
yes uh and anyone who's interested i
would highly recommend reading rule one
by phil towne uh great book
i asked my daughter what's her favorite
book right
danielle right
and she said well my favorite book is
guy spears book
i'm like ah come on
i'm your dad you could just at least
have be a homer you know
and uh but guy's book is phenomenal
monash's book is phenomenal yeah those
are that's a great start you had there
those you know one of the friends of
mine is
the guy jay mcinerney i don't know if
you know who he is but he'd started
square
and
he he talks about in his book called the
innovation stack which is probably i
think probably the most honest and
maybe the best book ever written about
entrepreneurial enterprises starting
something that's going to be
something you know you're not starting a
me too kind of a business to just you
know make a living and not have a boss
you're starting something to change the
world
he wrote this book
innovation stack a couple years ago
and um by the way since he's he he did
square he's gone on to become a member
of the federal reserve board in st louis
he's really moved
up into the elite circles of finance you
know um and jeremy basically said that
the people he was that mentored him
were books
effectively books i mean here's this guy
who changed the world really
by creating you know a credit
system for the little guy
and um and all of his mentors were
either dead people or
you know
and i think that's a wonderful way to
think about books and i'm really glad
you started off that way it's a good
good way to go yeah yeah i i cannot
express even just finding being said on
the right path of what types of books
was uh crazy because i don't know how
you feel about the education system
right now but uh
you know unless you're going into stem i
don't know i don't i don't understand
what's the point on it when you can pick
up a 20 30 book from some of the world's
brightest minds
it's uh yeah yeah you're familiar with
lilu right yep okay so lilu made a
comment to the columbia business school
students when he was giving a lecture
there a few years ago
um
after being frustrated with how little
they really knew about our style of
investing value investing
he was stunned these are two-year mba
students on their way to wall street
they didn't know anything they didn't
know the basics and so um he said look
this is why i don't hire you
i wouldn't hire anyone in this room
i mean there
he said no one who works for me has a
master's degree or really any experience
with
um
you know large corporations that are
involved in finance says i
other because they're not trainable they
don't unders they've already been warped
essentially is what he said
so i think the education system right
now is
goes a long way to warping people
because the
i don't know if this is fair exactly
maybe it's not but it feels like the
academics
have become arrogant
to a point where they
they no longer are looking at how what
really works in the world they're just
looking internally at what they think
works in the world and creating a world
based on that
and as a result you have well in our
world you know you have
gosh 50 years of modern portfolio theory
efficient market hypothesis
which is utter
three nobel prizes have been awarded in
the last 20 years to people who said
so
you just don't have to listen to me i
mean
great
economic
superstars like like uh
oh gosh robert schiller at yale you know
have have really proven that the idea
that the market is always rational and
that people always make these rational
decisions
is utter nonsense what what i haven't
seen a lot of in academia or even in
anybody really even with warren warren
or charlie or
is the recognition for why the market
can be irrational
why really smart people who did all the
academic stuff that you didn't do and
mostly that i didn't do
um are are able to make that mistake and
become irrational
and um you know you see comments from
all the way back to ben graham about how
the market
gets irrational
um but there but the why part of it
actually i think danielle my daughter
put her finger on which was that
these the people who have about 85 of
the money in the market
have a very major economic and career
incentive
to deal in short-term thinking
they don't get a benefit from being
right
if they're not right until three years
from now
they in fact they get fired keith
mccullough is a really good guy
he was working as a hedge fund manager
on a sub fund
and he made the right call on the real
estate meltdown in 2008 he was buying
insurance policies against those bonds
for about a year and his boss got more
and more agitated that keith was putting
his fund
money into these insurance premiums
that would ultimately ended up having
making it made a fortune the same ones
that
that
michael bury made a fortune on
and keith's keith
in november of 2007 he got fired
for refusing to back off
of what he knew was the right thing his
boss fired him and of course it was only
a couple months later that the whole
thing cratered
and uh and so you don't you don't you
pay a very high price in on wall street
for not being part of the consensus
and the high price that you pay
isn't a high price
that you like
you want to be part of the consensus in
wall street because you stay hired
because
a huge amount of money jeremy is is
invested
through banking funds and and pension
funds
more and more uh exchange-traded funds
that are just passive investors
and those well not so much the
exchange-rated funds that are passive
but the ones that are more active
are the fund of fund managers the
pension fund managers is hiring
people
like guy spear or monesh to manage the
money for them and they'll hire
i don't even know it's like california
teachers pension fund has like 200
billion dollars in the market
so they've they've hired a whole bunch
of different fund managers and that guy
sees his job
as managing those managers
and he's certainly not going to sit
there
waiting for some guy to be right for
three years if the market's going up and
this guy's portfolio isn't keeping up
with it he just isn't going to sit there
and the end result is that the
cautionary tales
of people like bruce berkowitz who was
dead right
in 2010 on bank of america aig and city
and later
you know made a bloody fortune by buying
those companies at those prices in 2010
but fundamentally got fired
by his own fund by all of these
pension funds pulling their money out he
he had 11 billion dollars come out of
his fund in a matter of a year
and so everybody knows the lesson it's a
cautionary tale don't stick your head up
you know you don't want to
you don't want to run a fund such that
you're trying to duplicate warren
buffett
that's a huge mistake if you're on wall
street because
buffett has been in cash for long
periods of time has underperformed the
market
uh from time to time and
you know he's not getting fired but you
are
and so that's a lesson that everybody
learned and as a result of that the
market becomes what we think of as
irrational is completely rational from a
fund manager's perspective who's on wall
street if apple computer is going down
like a brick you sell it
you don't sit there holding on to it
while it goes down 50 so you can buy
more
you get out of there so that you can
stay with your peer group and that's
what creates these
uh mispricings from time to time
and that when once you get that you
start to realize
whoa
then just an ordinary person who isn't
playing the game the way they do it on
wall street
absolutely can outperform fund managers
all you have to do is do what these
great teachers say to do be patient
have a few companies that you really do
understand and buy them when the market
fluctuates which it inevitably will and
that's that's it and then you're done
i have two questions on that and that is
um
yeah it is so fascinating uh
talking about efficient market theory um
you know
people are still holding on to it today
even saying well well now with the
internet and and all this feeds that pop
up on on your phone and laptop like it's
more efficient than ever before
because you have all the data you could
ever have i don't know how you feel
about this where it seems that with all
this news and
uh media being bombarded at us we're
becoming more more short-term
focused
than long-term so it's almost
uh i'm curious to get your thoughts do
you see that we're actually moving away
from long-term oriented with all this
new technology and rapid gratification
uh coming from the social media
uh absolutely 100 jeremy look at the
rise of robin hood
i mean this is a website that really was
groundbreaking they said come on and
just you can come on and trade for free
here
and it was effectively
i don't want to say preying on
uh
naive investors but a little bit right
because nothing's for free and so they
were basically running a little game
behind the scenes where you know you
weren't getting the best you weren't
getting the best price when you bought
it and you weren't getting the best
price when you sold they were taking a
little piece in the middle there um that
wouldn't have happened with other uh
brokers that where you charge the fee
and basically they gamified the idea of
investing
so you got you got all this stuff going
off that make it look really cool
um and i i think charlie munger is
appalled by robin hood because it
invites people to come in and gamble and
that's effectively what they're doing
and the more people that come in and
gamble
in a
what i would i would consider the late
stages of a really irrational bull
market
driven by federal reserve policies and
an enormous amount of money printing by
both you know fiscal and monetary policy
in the united states
driving this market sky high
makes a lot of people a winner who are
gambling right you buy call options and
you can become a big winner if
everything goes up and brings your boat
with it
so
um that
that the thing that's happening in the
market now is very similar to what
happened with real estate
uh from you know 2000 on when interest
rates went way down and people were were
encouraged to buy homes no money down
you end up with
i don't know uh
you end up with strippers owning six
houses in las vegas you know i mean you
you end up with these
these major market top signals that are
like holy crap and we're we're having
major market top
signals right now i mean not that the
the people on reddit are strippers but
but that
they're betting and it's just it's just
a big gamble and a big game and
um that has created
i think a kind of a mindset of very
short-term thinking and and the attempt
to get rich quick
uh getting home runs and
um the end of the end result is that
most most people are going to experience
a really negative result from that
you'll have a few people to get rich
very similar to what's going on with
bitcoin right bitcoin is driving a lot
of the emotion around investing in other
things
because of people getting very very rich
on bitcoin and ether and so on
um
by just gambling and betting on it all
and so
i don't
what happens is when you see enough
people around you who are stupider than
you are
and you know they are they're just
dumber than you are and they
you live realize that fool
just got rich on bitcoin i need to be
doing something or worse dogecoin or
dogecoin they got
there's a guy there's a guy who
borrowed everything he could get his
hands on and got 250 000 and put it all
in a dogecoin after a tweet by elon musk
okay and he made a million dollars in
two months
this guy and when they interviewed him
about this article about people getting
rich on crazy stuff
he said yeah no i'm not selling anything
you know when this gets to 10 million
then i'll take out a million dollars but
not till it gets to 10 million
so here's a guy who has no concept of
price versus value it's all
just
a magic set of numbers and a game
um that he's hoping to win with with a
bet and a lot of courage to stay with it
you know
so uh yeah i don't i don't think it's
gotten less volatile i think it's gotten
crazy more volatile and adding to the
volatility has to be the fact that we
now have a huge portion of the market
invested in passive strategy
which means that when things start going
down from the active investors realizing
things are overpriced and they're going
to get out
they will force the passive investors to
sell
which will accelerate the mood that
there's a reason to be fearful
and we will see
much quicker shifts in the market i
think we saw the first piece of that
back in march 2020
where if you weren't already
substantially in cash
things moved so quickly you didn't have
a chance to
adjust your portfolio
uh to get you know the famous warren
buffett bucket to come out there
and and catch that gold and uh you just
had this
there's nothing you could do it just
went down so damn fast
that you really didn't have a chance to
reset the portfolio and i think that's
the lesson for the future here is that
you have to get your wash tub out early
get your bucket out early
even if you're way early
and just be rational about the market
don't
uh you know don't try to um i wouldn't i
wouldn't want to sell anything that i
thought was still somewhat undervalued
or something i want to buy more of
um but i would i would liquidate things
that are
overpriced and uh they've ridden the
market to uh you know sort of a crazy
level
um why not get why not get the cash out
of there it can't you can't go on
forever and ever and ever at this rate
right so it won't if it can't it won't
and at some point it comes down
um and that volatility you will see i
think will be extreme when it comes down
you've got another factor by the way
just to throw in one more
one more brick on the camel's back is
that the baby boomers my generation of
investors is a
was the largest
um generation in american history and
now sort of our kids are creating
another generation like that
and that generation is well into their
retirement years in the 60s late 50s
all through the 60s and 70s and they
have to be concerned
to get their capital out of the stock
market because if it crashes and it's
down for 10 years a lot of people won't
be able to recover and they will have to
take money out when it's really a bad
time to do so and they will end up not
having them funny to retire fully and so
we end up with a lot more people going
back to work at walmart you know or 86
years old that's that's a sad scene
so that also is adding to the potential
for volatility is you have this huge
group of retirees who
may make a one-way trip out of the
market and then that'll be the end of
that capital and i remember you also um
on a podcast you did with danielle um
because i've been following for these
past five years
since i was 19. um
but uh
yeah i even remember you saying that
and i looked it up myself afterwards
because i was very curious about it
where you know people still say well you
know
you've never no one has lost money for
five to ten years when that's just not
true like there have been periods where
10 years plus and you just got your
money back um right
so right
i don't think people realize that as
well
and in this particular case the next the
next time there's let's say a five-year
gap let's just say everybody can agree
there can be a five-year gap
in that five-year gap at
at current
sort of headline inflation
of seven and a half percent
in that five-year period you will come
you'll see a devaluation of your buying
power of 50
or more
that's at the headline rate if we use
a calculation of inflation that was used
back in 1980 that they've stopped using
because it
it would require more increases in cost
of living on government programs
if we use the 1980 method our inflation
rates running 15 right now in which case
in five years
uh what did i say i meant your money
would be cut by one quarter the way
they're looking at it uh headline it'll
be cut in half if
you look at it on the
the uh sort of old inflation rate
calculator
and and so if you're just getting your
money back in five years the money you
got back isn't isn't what you what you
put in
it's only going to buy anywhere between
75 and 50 of what you
could have bought five years ago
and that's that's a disaster so they
the federal reserve is trying to get
this under control
but they've got a huge problem and that
is the moment they start
seriously increasing interest rates
then the calculation done on modern
portfolio theory of the value of the
market is goes negative on them
and p e ratios start to come down
and you have this sudden
uh beginning of a of a serious
um recession in the economy and a drop
in the market that would go with that so
they would have
lots of things that would go wrong the
real estate might flatten out or go down
stock market starts to drop we go into a
recession a lot of people unemployed the
mood of the country shaky
um and the federal reserve's job is to
kind of prevent all that kind of stuff
right so if they raise interest rates to
try to slow inflation down they're going
to run into real problems uh politically
and economically
and if they don't raise them
then you're running this risk of having
the currency devalue faster than your
investments can keep up with it
particularly if the market goes down so
i think there's there's a lot of
different kinds of risks here that
including you know volatility including
the the government programs including
the baby boomers
that will make this uh a time to i think
pay a great deal of attention to ray
dalio right now is what i would be doing
um i would read everything he's been
writing
i think he's got his his head screwed on
straight in many many ways
and
his basic recommendation is get yourself
into
an all-weather
program basically look at
holding a lot of different kinds of
things you want a certain kind of
diversification and you want to get a
diversification away from the u.s dollar
if the us dollar is going to be in
trouble
so
investing in places or currencies like
switzerland for example or norway
or singapore or china
would
would provide some diversification
against um
against the dollar devaluation because
it's really hard to keep up with dollar
devaluation if you know
stocks aren't going anywhere and the us
dollar is going down at seven and a half
percent a year
that's that's going to be a
real rough sledding so
yeah i think we're in for a rough a
rough go here if uh you use normal
thinking normal academic thinking about
what's happening
i think we're in for an extremely
exciting time if you are a monash babri
or a guy spear or a jeremy stickney or
you know
i think we're in for a blast i think
it's going to be really exciting and
this is where i think many people who
follow these kinds of investing
strategies will create generational
levels of wealth here
that's and that's going to be pretty
exciting i mean would you be pretty
excited if the market goes down you're
able to buy into it
and over the next let's say 12 years
you compound your money
at 36 a year just leaving it alone not
doing anything brilliant you just bought
in a bunch of companies they went back
up with all these fed policies
and the end result would be six doubles
right so if you put in a hundred grand
you got 2048 1.6 3.2
6.4 million
100 000 becomes 6.4 million you're well
on your way to generational wealth you
know
i i think the re
those numbers are going to be doable i
think i think people you'll see some
people 12 years from now
have done that kind of rate of return
and it's just a matter of um
understanding trimming the portfolio of
you know if you made a gain don't don't
expect it to keep going up it'd be okay
to take some off the table get educated
um
about uh even not just uh like personal
companies but you're actually also
saying uh paying attention to the macro
side of things these days because i know
a lot of investors within your space
they don't even think about the macro
but i think
those times are a bit i don't know if
you can do that right now or at least it
doesn't feel like that it doesn't feel
like that and
it's certainly
as much as warren buffett and charlie
talk about how they don't
they don't look at that yeah
they have remarkable timing when it
comes to being in
[Laughter]
uh cash how how does that happen
you could you could argue that
it happens
organically
if you are um
if you're investing the way warren did
back in the 50s and 60s and and early
70s
particularly 50s and 60s where he was
pretty aggressive about selling out
at around sticker
at around intrinsic value
and re you know recaching up the uh
reloading the portfolio to have another
opportunity
um which he was aggressively pursuing
right you gotta you gotta find the
opportunities
but he was uh out of out of stocks when
they hit intrinsic value
i don't think he does that so much
anymore with the kind of portfolio he's
got um
because he has a cash machine that's
producing so much cash flow
up into the headquarters that
it's not really
that useful for him to sell things off
because he still doesn't have any place
to put the 150 billion that he's
accumulating
in in cash
typically
most of us investors don't have that
problem we don't have
a cash machine that's just throwing
billions of dollars every month into our
into our hands with which we don't
have we just don't have any good
investments for so why would we sell
anything
you know we just hang on to it
um
and often just holding on to it's the
right answer right anyway because the
market just keeps going up
but boy i'll tell you if you're trying
to build a portfolio
you just don't want to go through a
five-year 10-year
flat line
where you know all you've got extra to
put into the market at at the
opportunity when things are on sale is
what you're able to save from your
you know
80 000 a year job
it's just it's just not enough capital
um you you really want to get your
portfolio if you're trying to build
something if you're trying if you're a
thousand error and trying to become a
millionaire
if you're trying to get that extra extra
zero or two onto the end of that
portfolio
then i think you do have to be a little
more aggressive and i think you do in
this market have to pay a little more
attention
uh to what's going on in the world and
and not that we're capable of knowing
where the market's going by any means
but at least it helps us understand why
it's so damn hard to find things that
are on sale right now
you know
at least you can you can see well okay
um if we were to look at
the relationship between
gdp in the united states and the overall
market price
um when buffett was making billions the
market was at about 50
of gdp
right right now it's at 250 percent of
gdp
it's like
huh
where can this go well 350 percent of
gdp
yeah it can if you're zimbabwe it might
do that right you just keep going up
until the year the currency is
absolutely worthless and then it crashes
and there's just yeah it's almost
it's just hard to believe that nothing
you know besides of course covid that a
crash hasn't come when you look at all
these metrics like most ipos in 2021
launched uh schiller pe
wilshire gdp just
it's just it's just insanity um which
you know a lot of people are actually
buying into like there are even books
being made called the death of
the deficit myth and like we're in a new
era and it doesn't matter anymore so
um that when i start seeing stuff like
that and it feels like 1999 to me i want
to go listen to the prince song it's
just
man here we are again where now we have
new rules it's not about earnings it's
about revenue it's about actually it's
about clicks
it's you know it's just
we have to find another metric because
that old one is just too stuck in the
mud and you see that right there a year
before a year or two
before it all collapses back to economic
reality
and i you know i think charlie i don't
know did you have a chance to watch
charlie's uh annual thing yeah yeah
pretty great and basically he's making
the point
that this is uh
you know it's kind of amazing and it can
continue and we don't know how long it
can continue
but i think he's making the point that
it can't continue forever
and uh when it resets it's going to be
really ugly really okay
and i think if you're like me you want
to be ready for really
ugly right you wanna you wanna be
as anti-fragile as you can be as
anti-snowflake as you can possibly get
right without without you don't wanna be
you don't wanna be rigid that's not what
i mean right you want to be
you just want to be
flowing with it to a point where
you benefit from the chaos that comes
that's that's kind of how you want to be
um
i i think you know the a metaphor might
be an oak is really really good standing
against a storm oaks last hundreds of
years
you know and if you take an axe and you
slam it into that oak tree
it will bear that scar
for the next 300 years right forever for
as long as that thing is alive
and
if you did but the scar is a very small
scar right you hit it and nothing much
happens
you take that same ax and you slam it
into a pond
and it's a huge splash
but within moments
the pond is back to the way it was
right i think that's that's the
difference between
the high degree of flexibility and a
kind of a stuck
you know rigid system and so we want to
be highly flexible we want to be able to
move with
what's going on
and move quickly and get back to kind of
a fundamental stasis a fundamental
confidence that we're in the right place
in this kind of a positioning and so
the reason i'm recommending dalio
strongly is that
dalio is a ma he's the best
macro investor in the world as far as i
know
he runs bridgewater he did until he
basically kind of quasi retired now
and his job for 36 years compounding
money at 18 a year which is remarkable
and i think he has 200 billion dollars
under management right now with a b
and he basically has been able to move
capital around according to what's going
on with these macro events
and right now he's basically saying
you've got to get ready
for whatever's coming down the pike
and it could be
massive inflation it could be that the
stock you want to be in stocks because
they do well with massive inflation for
a while
it could be that commodities rule for
the next 10 years
um as inflation takes off it could be
that we need protection from gold and
his idea is you you you need about four
buckets of different things so you know
one bucket might be real estate another
bucket might be stocks another bucket
might be
some treasury inflation protected bonds
and maybe another bucket is commodities
and you sort of uh adjust for that since
we don't have a perfect crystal ball
but what you don't do is you don't get
rigid and say oh well
the right answer for the last 20 years
has been to hold stocks no matter what
and we've come out really well with that
and that's what everyone is recommending
just hold stocks and stay with it that
that is fine if you've got enough money
yeah you got enough money you got enough
time you'll be fine but if you're trying
to build something
then that is not so fine and i don't i
don't know anybody who built anything
that did that
i'm really curious um now this is uh
to get your your thoughts on um what
i've been thinking regarding my own
portfolio that is a hundred percent in
cash uh now this is just educational
purposes this is not advice um
but uh
with my business um uh evan being my
business partner and doing youtube
consulting which is my business um i've
been able to
by by august i will have a million
dollars in cash which is which was my
goal
um by 25 actually congratulations thank
you uh at 19
i was at your uh seminar in atlanta and
at the end you hand out those cards of
like what is your goal write it on the
back and it was to have a million
dollars by 25 so i'll talk about that
later but it's funny how i actually i'm
going to hit that so
um
congratulations thank you um what did
you start with oh god ten thousand
dollars that is awesome man
yeah uh grocery store and then uh and
yeah now today so it's just been a crazy
ride
but you're very close to your other goal
then
you're getting very close to your other
goal of
just investing
yeah with my consulting business i'm
putting
around 30 hours per week and now moving
in this direction i would love to put
another 30 hours into just
mastering investing so
that is the goal
i mean i'm sure as any of these guys
have told you it's it's a dream job it's
a dream job that's why you don't see
anybody quit
you know it's like all these guys are
dying with their boots on you know it's
like
[Music]
they're staying in the saddle and and
they don't want to leave um you know
walter schloss
i think he retired retired a week before
he died
and he turned over his investment fund
to his son who was 72.
i finally got the top job
it's amazing how
it is not just
it's not wall street at all it is a mix
of personal development psychology
investing
and truly figuring out what the meaning
of life is for you like
you know you see you doing polo and
training horses while doing investing
and you know everyone has their own
life balance which i i really admire
it's not
so ruthless one size fits all there's no
one-size-fits-all man yeah and you sort
of you want to live
you want to live your dream and
and the beauty of doing that as quickly
as possible is that as soon as you start
living it that dream will change
your dreams grow
over time uh and and shrink in a way
it's like you can have dreams of you
know
expanding out into influence and then
as you do so it may be that you just
wish you were you start to dream being
back in a
a small understandable world that you
you you don't mind all these things
going on around you but the most
important thing i think is that
life is a
life is a river i mean it it flows and
it turns and it has rapids in it and it
has big huge eddies where you're going
nowhere
and um if you can navigate that river
you you do so i think by understanding
your dharma understanding where you're
where should i be right now in the
current or if i want to
have a life that flows with maximum joy
and maximum impact and
maximum
effectiveness of what i'm supposed to be
as a human being
staying with the current of that river
where it's supposed to flow
is super super key
and if your life is like mine it'll have
a lot of turns in it you know there'll
be there'll be major bends in that river
and
um
and the beauty is is learning how to
stay in the current learning how to
learn how to be in the flow of your own
life where you feel that the change is
now right the time is now to bend around
this and move to
this next thing
and god man being an investor my whole
life has allowed me to do that it's
given me the freedom
to
wear a lot of different hats in my life
and and be a lot of
try a lot of different kinds of things
and
and uh
and really
just kind of try to be in that flow and
it's weird it's like it's not even like
trying a lot of different things it's
just like becoming the next thing
you know
yeah it's that's kind of the deal and
man i can't think of anything
that would that's better than what i did
honestly and i think probably warren and
charlie and guy and manesha all feel the
same way it's like
somehow i was so
bloody fortunate to get on to this
early enough and wasn't really early i
was in my 30s when i did
you know
and um
and then you know just that i was
fortunate to stay with it through the
the early part of anything when you're
learning right anything from
snowboarding to investing is bumpy
there are things that you're going to
fall down on
and you're going to skin your knee and
it's just like staying with it having
confidence that that this will work out
to get you through the doubts
has been absolutely life-changing for me
and now generations like plural
of my family as we're now into
grandchildren
it's so life-changing and you're you you
will have changed the lives assuming you
end up with kids and they end up with
kids and they end up with kids
down the road you what you're doing will
have changed all of those lives
forever
i mean they they will not
have money issues they will be all about
dharma they will be all about what am i
put on this world to do
because
i understand money and i understand how
to replicate it and i will never
have to be broke and worrying about
money
powerful stuff what this does what this
life is that you you pick to to get into
and i'm so thankful that it was
your group of books i picked up and not
some
random person who's
flashing money and driving lamborghinis
in dubai and
you know um which is fun if you're if
that happens to be where you're at right
yeah yeah if you need to drive
lamborghinis in dubai by god
get it and go do it and check that box
and then move on yeah
yeah absolutely but it is very much when
i hear you speak i always hear the the
uh
the personal development
psych side of things which is
people don't associate that with money
they think of the show billions where
i love that show but it's just you know
bobby axelrod and being being ruthless
right it's fun to see the worst of us
isn't it it's great it is
it's such a comedy show if you truly
understand it um but i i do want to ask
you back on you know how to navigate the
uh the river and the tides in just one
sec but i i want to go back to um my
thought process regarding that now that
i have this big portfolio and inflation
being as high as it is is probably much
higher than that since i live in toronto
canada so
it's not five percent as canada's as it
is um
but uh
yeah um
but
uh
what i'm thinking is um
uh and just let me know if you have any
thoughts on this where with inflation if
this takes uh i know that i need to have
the bulk in cash um for for because i do
see a storm coming down the road um
and but i don't feel like i can be
entirely out of the market so what i was
thinking is a 25
find great companies at fair prices if
interest rates stay low they do great
well having 75 in cash do you see any
things i'm missing in that strategy or
something i should be thinking about
um
as i try and
buffer against a bit of inflation is
there any
little rate of return i can make what
we're doing is just we as my analysts
and i are busy trying to find
those needles in the haystack right of
really wonderful businesses that really
are on sale
right now
and because of that are having their own
sort of depression
which means they're very unlikely or
their own form of recession they're very
unlikely to be affected by
a market meltdown they're they're
they're melted
um maybe they go down another 25 or
something but they're really melted down
that's what we're looking for but our
criteria is that they have to be
anti-fragile they have to be companies
which will in fact do very well with
inflation so huge moats big big moats
that allow them pricing power
so as their costs rise
then their prices can rise and um and
that makes them anti-fragile and
unfortunately those companies are pretty
well known all over the world and are
bit up to the moon most of them so you
really need some sort of
weird crisis like what happened in china
for example might be a place to look
uh for something
um i know monash is looking around in
turkey they're having an absolute
currency catastrophe
so you you do sort of you know try to
find where where things might have gone
on sale temporarily because of something
uh that's happened some event that's
happened
um
but if i if i was starting all in cash
and i couldn't find any of those i
wouldn't force my way into a company
i wouldn't say okay well now i'm going
to adjust what i'll pay for this because
i just need to be in something
rather than that i i would i shouldn't
say i wouldn't do that i would sort of
do that
i would sort of force my way in but in a
weird sort of way um
and i think matt matt peterson shares a
certain amount of this with me um but we
i i'll trade that that company let's say
there's a company that's
20 below what i think it's worth
right
it's not way down there where i want to
buy it
but
i will start selling
um i'll start doing some structured
trades on that i'll start
selling put options against that
ideally my ideal is i can sell that put
option
um strike price
less the premium that i'm getting at the
margin of safety price and if i can get
it down to where i really think that's a
great price
i'd be happy to accept that stock
because i'm becoming obligated to buy it
for
some of the listeners who may not be
that comfortable with
options
we we try to use options we try to be
the house
right if you're gambling we
we don't want we don't love being the
person who's putting down a little money
and trying to make a fortune
we want to be the house we we want to be
able to take that gamble and so we're
taking that gamble we're saying okay
great i will buy that stock from you
at this very much lower price and you'll
pay me for that insurance policy i'm i'm
ensuring you that you can get out you'll
pay me for that and the person doing
that might be a hedge fund manager might
be a bank fund manager wanted to be sure
that things you know don't go below this
certain level uh because they're trying
to keep up with their peer group and so
they're willing to pay money
every month or one one big one a year or
something where they will
buy that
right to force me to buy their stock at
that price we've agreed on well if that
price we've agreed on is a price i'm
willing to pay in the first place then i
have no risk when it comes to
the option the purchase of the
underlying stock i'm i'm trying to buy
it at that price for pete six i guess
what the sec or securities exchange guys
would say is well you do have a risk
because if you're willing let's say
you're
the stock's at 100
and i obligate myself to buy it at 70
and get paid well to do that
such that let's say my net price is 63
okay i've got a 63 basis if if i'm put
this stock if i'm when i'm obligated to
buy it i have to buy it at 70 but i
already got seven dollars so i'm really
there at 63.
if i'm
happy with that at 63 i don't feel like
i've got risk but the securities guys
would go well what if the price is at
50.
you know you've lost 13
says well
yeah in your world
but in my world i've bought this
wonderful ten dollar bill
for under five dollars and if now it's
available for three dollars i'm gonna
buy some more
yep
right
so um
i love that kind of way of creating cash
flow that
offsets the impact on the rest of the
portfolio
of the decline in the purchasing power
of the currency and are you looking at
um
like 20 of your portfolio doing options
is there
about that
about 20
um
back when it was just
fun to create cash flow it was much less
because we could use the whole portfolio
to buy wonderful companies
now it's very hard for me to find
places to put all that money
and so
we're doing we've upped it to 20
and um i may up it to 30 uh here in the
near future because there's
very very little risk let's say i did
one where
you know prices have gotten so out of
hand that
um
i can hardly do this thing at intrinsic
value right i mean
the stocks are above intrinsic value but
let's say i can find one where
i can sell the the strike the put option
strike price at
maybe 80 percent of intrinsic value so
i've got some cushion there
a little bit a little bit of a cushion
i'll i'll do that deal if i like the
company
it's something i feel like okay if i get
stuck in this
uh this certainly isn't the end of the
world and what i mean by that is what my
intention to do is not if i'm put the
stock
then what i'm going to do is immediately
turn around and sell the calls
so and you'll find if you if you do that
if you learn how to do that that the
premiums being paid on at the money
calls which is typically where they are
when you get put to stocks they're right
at the money
you sell those calls you're getting paid
three or four times the level you got
paid when you sold the put in the first
place and the result is this
this back and forth
cash
cow
on a company
that you know most companies even if
they're overpriced they're going to go
sideways for a bunch of time and then
they're going to drop or they're going
to go up and then they go sideways and
re and reconsolidate
and all that sideways stuff you're
creating cash flow
like crazy it's like
in and out um over one month
actually we do these things relatively
short periods seven days ten days
um
and the the result is
i don't know in our portfolio we're not
real happy unless we're making more than
20 a year on that chunk so let's say
that we're able to do that on 30 percent
of the portfolio making 20
that puts a six percent base on the
entire portfolio if nothing else happens
we've pretty we've gotten pretty close
to covering a seven percent seven and a
half percent
discount in the cash cash value
right so yeah i feel and since we're
about half in cash our six percent would
reflect about a
you know inflation would have to be
around 12 percent that for it to not be
offset
and for viewers this is not like
game stop options trading whatsoever
this is entirely different thing um to
look up um and uh yeah people don't even
realize that warren buffett is one of
the biggest options traders out there so
something for for viewers to definitely
look into and i will be doing uh further
investigation myself into uh yeah it's
pretty cool when warren was getting
going
he
ran into what we run into inevitably as
as an investor that does what we do what
we call a rule one investor you're going
to end up focusing on not losing money
that's such a huge critical focus point
and in order to make sure you don't do
that you don't want to buy into things
when they're too pricey or you don't
understand them
and so there can be times when they're
just nothing to buy
and warren ran into those times back in
the 60s and it's really instructive to
go read his early letters
in the 1960s letters the buffett
partnership letters
those are where he talks about his three
different categories of investment
where he has i forget his names for them
the generals i think are just public
stocks
um and then i i think he called it
workouts or something like that where he
was basically doing merger acquisition
arbitrage
and his his view was when i can't find
anything to buy i can always take a lot
of the cash
and put it into you know 10
arbitrage opportunities here
where i can make a pretty good bet
that i'll make a decent rate of return
over a fairly short period of time and
he did that to create cash flow
and increase rates of return for years
and years and years now merger arbitrage
because
everybody knows everything about what's
going on with mergers that's harder and
harder to do there's there's a couple
out there right now which are kind of
interesting merger arbitrages that we're
involved in but by and large it's pretty
hard to do
um and we've substituted options trading
for that kind of following along on the
on the footsteps of uh ed thorpe um
who as you know wrote the book on
how to how to
count cards for blackjack in las vegas
and he made ed made i think 200 million
dollars personally
and never had a losing year i think i
think his average compounder rate of
return was 28 for over 20 years
um and what he did principally was what
i was just talking about doing there
using using options a little different
way than most people would in the market
well worth learning jeremy for sure i
will definitely be doing that um and on
that note um
uh i i know a lot of you know i can
quote pretty much any warren buffett
quote there is i i know a lot of maybe
you could say the um
uh
the the
i don't know how to put it but uh just
uh
you know the the the life lessons of
warren and charlie you could say um but
i i need to actually now that i'm in a
position with my business and investing
to put in the 30 hours per week i need
to
really start being
digging into the weeds and doing the
application side of things so
i'm really curious to know what your
daily
setup looks like how your week is
scheduled like do you have a block for
looking at the macro side of things do
you have a block for researching options
i'd be very curious to know what areas
you
really tackle throughout your week
to stay on top of things
well my friend i'm
i'm an older guy
with with some bad habits
and it's really hard to break them and
one of the things i'm working on is to
try to be
more structured than what i am
and there's there's a lot of there's a
lot of things i have to be structured
around
that are disciplinarian kinds of issues
and in other words things that i
wouldn't
maybe just yeah i can't wait to go do
this kind of stuff
because otherwise my day can get away
from me really easily
i mean as you know we've got an
education company
that i have to be involved in certain
amount of time during the day
and um
and so that that is just
becomes a fairly heavy load relative
to being able to spend enough time on
investing so i have to be structured
about that kind of time
so what i do is i go morning from
typically about seven o'clock until
about nine
is i read
that might go actually i should do more
accurately seven to about ten
realistically
i read and read and read and read and i
read
newspapers i read magazines i read books
but i read
and then
10ks and so on
and then
actually no in the morning i don't do
10ks and it's all just reading
whatever i feel like
it's kind of
if i'm in fourth grade it's open reading
time
and then
um i go down and work out i try to work
out at about 10 o'clock i get a workout
in before the day really gets rolling
i'm not too worried about being on the
market when it opens i don't care when
it what it's doing almost anytime
occasionally i might be there when they
open for something maybe an options
trade that that we might need to adjust
but
by and large
waiting from 9 30 to 10 is just kind of
getting amateur hour out of the way and
then
let's go see where the market's really
going today if i if i want to be on the
market but from about 10 30 or so
sorry
10 30 11 depending on how long the
workout is
um
i will be on the market looking at our
portfolio
and um or reading 10ks
or looking at what my team has put
together
in the form of a story
all right we have a very structured
story
that uh gives us
a a very specific set of questions or
checklists that we have to check the
boxes on
um the first part of that by the way is
totally not even proprietary it's bill
ackman 101.
you know he's got an eight-point
checklist that he emphasized just a
couple years ago as being really
critical they got away from it they made
some mistakes and they came back to it
and that checklist is a wonderful
quick uh analysis we actually
built bill it's an eight-point checklist
and we turned it into a nine-point
checklist because bill doesn't take a
look at the value there
but we do so we call it the nasty nine
so our our nasty the nasty nine comes
from an old special forces
name of the
most miserable
uh
uh course that you had to go through
like obstacle course that you had to go
through just
absolutely horrible
for
if you're getting through the green
beret qualification program
and they call it the nasty nick
and so we're calling this the nasty nine
i love that
you've got to get through the
qualification course before you can make
it to the place where we'll really start
digging in
um
so we'll be i'll be looking at those
that are coming from austin and travis
and brian
and um i'll be doing some of those
myself and so that time frame from about
10 30 11
just blows right through usually you
know lunch lands on my desk in the form
of a sandwich and we just keep going
um
and then by
mid to late afternoon i shift over
to some of the education company stuff
then um
i'm back out again this is sort of
structured to keep my head screwed on
the way i like it screwed on is i'm out
on a horse by about five o'clock
i try to ride every single day even if
it's not a real structured ride like i'm
training or
jumping something or
doing
doing anything aggressive i might just
get on a horse and ride walk him out
and um it's good for me to connect with
my horse that way
got a i've got a horse i'm building
into a just a fabulous source he's
pretty young guy
he's an ex-stallion that we bred for a
number of years really well bred and
then we
made a mcgeldin and uh
he's he's still he's still pretty
stalliony so he requires a lot of
connection you know he doesn't really
want to bond as much he's like a
standing off so i'll spend time with him
uh and that kind of that kind of does
then then i go down to my
mother-in-law's who's right next door
where her house we build a house for and
she's the most wonderful person on the
planet
i love her deeply and she puts a dinner
together every night for my wife and me
and we go down there often a lot of
people from the farm come in
and we grab a bite and then it's back to
reading it's like we go to bed pretty
early but i'll go back on to reading
again and i'll be reading
just depends on how locked in i get i'll
read anywhere from about 8 30 to
midnight or 8 30 to 10 30. it's kind of
when do the lights go off so the reading
part if you start adding this up
you see what i'm saying yep
it gets too much
the biggest part of what i do is reading
it's like seven hours a day or something
of reading
and um i've found that to be
just the most enjoyable thing and and
it helps me
be a better investor to just have a real
good sense of a lot of different kinds
of things and it's very charlie
monger-ish
yeah if you if you want to study that
more just listen entirely about it
so that's kind of that's kind of a rough
structure now in the middle of all that
all sorts of things happen
that change everything and that that
happens
lots of days right so
i try to have the structure to make sure
that most of the days i've got the job
done and then there's days where i just
have to do something different hopefully
that that helps you a little bit see
what very much you guys doing out there
yeah yeah no that is uh that's
definitely um very curious to to hear
the different sides of what people do on
a daily basis um and now you got me
curious i'm i'm wondering what guy does
all day
i haven't ever asked he he said he he
really needs to read more that's what he
needs to do so um i think that was his
main main goal for for 2022 read more um
yeah
because i i know when running a fund you
can also get caught up on managing
clients and not actually doing what you
love to do so
i don't know if my investing is gonna go
just for myself and grow my capital or
if down the road i do wanna
discover that side of things who knows
but um well i know i know that if you're
running a
fund with big
uh big investors in it
i mean really you want what you want to
do i think is take a a note from warren
i'm not so sure about charlie but i
think probably he did something similar
but basically they basically said look
don't don't don't call me
all right i mean that that was basically
the essence of it is don't call me
because
i'll be in touch with you once a year
um and you have updates that are on a
regular basis
that we may send out quarterly or
whatever
but i think
having your investors understand what
the structure is
is really important because you can be
buried
by a lot of good intentioned investors
they can they can they can take you down
they can make it that really all you're
doing all day long is marketing which
essentially is taking care of people
so they will stay in the fund or they'll
come into the fund
and that marketing side is brutal it
really is and so
what you want to do is i think if you
have a way to do this is you want to
build your reputation which you already
have done
remarkable amount of work in building a
reputation because that's your calling
card that's your track record
and then i think
um you want to use the structure that
guy and manesh and i and warren and
charlie have all used which is some form
of limited partnership
to bring in capital
and then manage it
and so
the key is who's who owns the capital
that you're bringing in
if they're nervous investors like
pension funds they're going to be in and
out and gone
uh you know the day that you are not
keeping up with the market is the day
they start leaving and all of that
effort
all that marketing you know the stuff
you watch on billions where he's in
there making
all this yep
ideally you don't have to do that
ideally you it's word of mouth that
carries it from one person to another
um that this guy
you know you really you gotta you gotta
get interested in jeremy because he's
really doing a great job that this guy
stickney is an amazing fund manager
and by the way don't expect him to
answer your phone calls because he can't
do that
right right
you build a reputation
based on not
i like you
and we play golf together but that you
deliver the goods on a on a five to ten
year basis i'm delivering the goods
because ultimately that's what people
should care about you don't i don't
think you want to fall into the category
of financial advisor
who knows nothing about investing and
everything about selling
and what they do is they schmooze and
schmooze and schmooze and schmooze and
play golf and try to hold on to the
money and the assets under management
and if they're really good at that
they're really a nice person and they're
they're fun to be around and you like
going to ball games with them and
playing some golf collect their 2 fees
every year yeah you collect that fee and
and and your investors are all like yeah
i don't know
why move to somebody else they're going
to do the same thing as this guy does so
i'm really in it for the relationship
that's not what you want you don't want
people in it for the relationship you
want them
in it because they know in five years
you're gonna do better for them
safer you're gonna do better safer than
any other investment they could do
i mean they can gamble and they might do
better over five years or ten years but
they're not going to be able to do it
safely as in safer than a mutual fund
but investing with you could be safer
than a mutual fund with returns
substantially higher than that
that's nirvana for an investor but they
have to come to believe it and the way
they come to believe it is that track
record right and in terms of you know
making that decision and of course i
don't have to make it for a while just
keep building up my track record um
that uh
when it comes down to of course you have
to make sure you get the right investors
or just building wealth on your own um
do you find that managing other people's
money just it just adds that extra
accountability factor for you to show up
every day versus just managing your
money um
i'm trying to figure out because uh
what would be because i know it's much
easier to just do your own thing forget
everyone else
and you grow your capital um
so i'm just curious what is the biggest
driver
um
for you
uh
when it comes to managing other people
is it just the accountability or
i think the the biggest driver for me
really and the reason i went back into
it was that i wanted to see our students
have an option
that they understood as a place to put
money while they were busy
learning how to handle it themselves so
my nirvana for me
would be that all of my students take
all their money back
and and go do it on their own the way
you're doing it but that's hard for
people especially people who have a lot
of money
um it's very difficult to just suddenly
go from i'm i don't know what i'm doing
to now i've learned something
you have to build your confidence like
you've built you've been building your
confidence for five years six years
and and now your confidence level is
quite high
you probably could easily accept 50
million dollars and not be freaked out
of your mind
right but if a billion dropped on your
plate that could be a little scary right
so there's some levels that you have to
rise to
uh before your comfort level get you you
have to get comfortable there so you can
sleep at night and feel confident you
know what you're doing and so for me
that's that's my nirvana but
i decided to do it because essentially
i'm doing all the work anyway right
i'm
absolutely i'm if when you're managing
millions of dollars of your own money
you're you're paying attention the
biggest difference is that i don't have
to build a portfolio i'm protecting a
portfolio so that's a little
right i can slack off
so i love your your your thought i mean
in your question
um that there's a certain sort of
selfish purpose
to you know beyond fees and all that
sort of thing that that i have in
managing other people's money is that it
actually keeps me focused
and it absolutely does and that is also
why i teach
it absolutely keeps me focused i have an
obligation to be in that virtual
classroom
on a regular basis and
be coherent and have something useful to
say
that's current
and so those two things are
i think
i think really lifetime things and
i mean i don't see warren not wanting to
teach it's you know it's a blast and it
and it he was asked once i'm sure you
know this warren was asked what his
legacy what he wanted his legacy to be
right and he he said i i hope i'm known
as a as a great teacher
yeah that has stuck with me uh as soon
as i heard that like that's why i have
him and charlie on my wall the the
ethics it's not about how much net worth
they are the ethics they have yeah i
have to i have to show you this
on the screen
over here
oh wow
there we go that is that is beautiful i
must say
and that that's just half of the the
book ends
and there's charlie
oh my god that is sonia i look at these
guys every day
and
in my own way thank them every day for
what they taught me
um what they taught my teacher
uh it
it's remarkable and i also use these
guys as a kind of accountability right
you have a certain obligation to pass
down
this knowledge in as pure a form as you
can do it
be as honest with it as you can
um while still realizing that
you know you're not going to do it
exactly how they did it it's like i do i
do options trades
um
maybe more regularly than warren does i
know he does he does tons of them and
they're huge
and he does put options
regularly um so i i do do something
similar but maybe do more of something i
don't know i i try to keep it pure i
really do
um and why not because they're the best
investors in the world and if you want
to if you want to be the best you you
follow the best that's that's that's
just the story of it right there
congratulations to you for doing exactly
that you're following the best and
you're you're getting some of the best
people in the world to talk with you
which is really great that's awesome
yeah i've been uh super fortunate
thank you um
very well it's been an amazing journey
and just even leveraging youtube to be
able to do that uh
yeah so it's been uh amazing um to have
that uh but then also the books like if
you're for viewers if you're just
looking to get into investing i would
highly recommend i'm just gonna plug
this invest it this book is amazing so
um
and uh yeah it is uh really good uh but
the one thing i i guess i really want to
end off um on is
going back to the river you know going
back to navigating the stream um
for people in their 20s who you know
think like i will you know my generation
baby boomers hide the generation of
building wealth i have the generation of
losing wealth like i will never be able
to create the life i want uh it just
feels like that for so many 20 year olds
what are the key habits that you would
say just
have helped you or the people um
that that you have studied uh what would
be some of the habits that people should
really
adopt um and start to to pick up on
i think the habit that changed my life
the most was when i learned to meditate
honestly
um that was gigantic it it took me from
being kind of a loner
working as a guide out in the grand
canyon and spending a lot of time
alone and
when i'd travel i would travel alone you
know i'd kind of pursue
my
interests around the world different
places and
and um
and i had i had a pretty good chip on my
shoulder from being in the military and
so i think
the meditation that i got into was a
gigantic change it
it
i guess i it really got a lot of stress
out of me from just being quiet 20
minutes twice a day and um and
meditating
i got a lot of i got a lot of this
stress out and that was a big deal
because stress stress interferes with
you not just your health but also the
way your mind is working you know
how how comfortable you are at just kind
of
you know letting things unfold at their
own pace
was um was hard for me and i was you
know i tended to be
aggressive about trying to make things
happen
and i think when you start to connect
deeply inside
um you are a little more aware of
in a very subtle level maybe not even in
a thinking level but your intuition
about where to go next what to do next
especially in your 20s right what what's
what's the next best thing for me now
because you're kind of you know people
build a resume and they do it very
intentionally for for the corporate
world right you're going to go to this
school and you're going to get that
degree
um
that's kind of what you're doing here is
you're sort of building your dharma
one step at a time i mean because you go
to that school doesn't mean that's where
you stay
it's it's just a stepping stone
to where you have to where ultimately
you'll be and since you have no idea in
your 20s
where you will ultimately be
none none zero
as long as you keep
following that intuition it's it's
dialing in
something deep inside
where you'll end up being you have no
idea it can be so different than where
you are i mean believe me as a river
guide and soldier
i had no idea i'd be on stage
in front of
i mean as many as 30 40 000 people
talking about this i that was
inconceivable it would have been
just like
you can't you can't
have anything meaningful there or that i
would even write a book about any of
this or that i would even have money
was all not part of my plan
so the idea that you can have a plan to
say i'm going to be here by the time i'm
50 years old i think can only make you
rigid
it can only make you like i'm i'm forced
into this box
by my own
rigidity
and i think having an idea like okay i
want to be wealthy enough to do whatever
i want in the world i love the idea like
your dharma i think absolutely could
become a fund manager this isn't to say
you can't have a 30-year plan yeah right
if that plan is clear as a bell to you
that's dharma man you just get going on
it right our daughter is our daughter is
a surgeon and that's a gigantic long
plan
and she's really happy that she's a
surgeon that's her dharma and so um i'm
just saying that the
thing that i learned the most the most
important thing to me that i've done
is to learn to meditate and have that
withdraw from all that activity and all
that thinking
and just settle down quietly twice a day
and
that's changed everything for me
everything i i need to start doing that
or at least test that out
that is one thing i don't do but uh i
will definitely um
look up that take a look at it it's
not not so much the meditation per se
like the way i do it it is just
transcendental meditations around the
world and ray dalio happens to be doing
the same thing he's been doing it for as
long as i have
and and credits it the same way i'm
crediting it
but there's a lot of different paths
to being silent inside
my wife she doesn't like to meditate she
likes to walk in the woods
and kind of transcend there and just be
with the woods
be in the in the wilderness and you know
other people kobe bryant is a great
basketball player in america just
talked about being in the zone when he's
playing basketball and having everything
go silent and just
being
watching what was going on
um there's i think it's an accessible
thing to get down deep inside and i
think you can do it lots of ways
look for what's working best for you
yeah definitely and you know
it's funny that we started out with
you you bringing up squarespace and
their innovation stack and with all the
reading the meditation
the habits it's almost you're building
your own personal
innovation stack
but uh
yeah
thank you uh so much
it's been incredible to talk with you uh
where can people find you the best
besides of course
making sure they read this book um we've
invested
and yeah we're online at rule1
investing.com
and uh there's a lot of tools there you
can play with and
ideas for you to think about learning
this stuff um and then you know
everybody should just pay a lot of
attention to this podcast this is a
great podcast you're doing perfect well
done man thank you so much all right
look forward to seeing you soon
if you like that video you need to check
out this one right here with guy spear
on how to start investing and building
wealth for yourself and i'll see you
there
investing is an infinite game jeff bezos
he doesn't walk around saying look how
rich i am if anything he says look at
the amazing company that i've built